in this video we're going to talk about
kinetic energy and we're also going to
think about how to calculate it
so you can already imagine based on the
word kinetic which is referring to
motion
that this is the energy that an object
has by virtue of its motion
and when we talk about energy we're
talking about its capacity to do
work so just based on that early
definition
of kinetic energy which of these two
running backs
do you think has more kinetic energy
this gentleman
on the left whose mass is a hundred
kilograms
and who is traveling at a speed of two
meters per second
or the gentleman on the right who has a
mass of 25 kilograms
and who's traveling with a speed of four
meters per second pause this video and
think about that
all right now let's think about this
together so i'm first just going to give
you the formula for kinetic energy
but then we are going to derive it so
the formula for kinetic energy
is that it's equal to one-half times the
mass of the object
times the magnitude of its velocity
squared or another way to think about
it's its speed
squared and so given this formula
pause the video and see if you can
calculate the kinetic energy for each of
these running backs
all right let's connect the let's
calculate the kinetic energy for
this guy on the left it's going to be
one half
times his mass which is 100 kilograms
times the square of the speed so times
4 meters squared per second squared have
to make sure that we square the units as
well
and this is going to be equal to one
half times 100 is 50 times 4
is 200 and then the units are kilogram
meter squared per second squared
and you might already recognize that
this is the same thing as kilogram
meter per second squared times meters
or these are really the units of force
times distance
or this is the units of energy which we
can write as 200
joules now let's do the same thing for
this running back that has
less mass kinetic energy here is going
to be one half
times the mass 25 kilograms
times the square of the speed here so
that's going to be
16 meter squared per second squared
and then that gets us we're essentially
going to have one half times 16 is 8
times 25
200 and we get the exact same units and
so we can go straight to 200 joules
so it turns out that they have the exact
same kinetic energy
even though the gentleman on the right
has one-fourth the mass and only
twice the speed we see that we square
the speed right over here so that makes
a huge difference
and so their energy due to their motion
they have the same capacity to do
work now some of you are thinking where
does this formula come from
and one way to think about work and
energy is that you can use
work to transfer energy to
a system or to an object somehow and
then that energy is that object's
capacity
to do work again so let's imagine some
object that has a mass
m and the magnitude of its velocity or
its speed
is v so what would be the work
necessary to bring that object that has
mass m to a speed of v assuming it's
starting at a standstill
well let's think about it a little bit
work
is equal to the magnitude of force in a
certain direction
times the magnitude of the displacement
in
that direction which we could write like
that sometimes they use s
for the magnitude of displacement as
well and so
what is the force the same thing as we
know that the force
is the same thing as mass times
the acceleration and we're going to
assume that we have constant
acceleration just so we can simplify
our derivation here and then what's the
distance that we're going to travel
well the distance is going to be the
average magnitude of the velocity or we
could say the average speed
so i'll write it like this times the
time
that it takes to accelerate the object
to a velocity of v well how long does it
take to accelerate an
object to a velocity of v if you're
accelerating it at a
well this is just going to be the
velocity divided by the acceleration
think about it
if you're going trying to get to a
velocity of 4 meters per second
and you're accelerating at 2 meters per
second per second
4 divided by 2 is going to leave you
with 2
seconds and if you're starting at a
speed of 0
and you're going to a magnitude of a
velocity or speed
of v and you're assuming constant
acceleration
your average velocity is just going to
be
v over two so this is just v
over two and then we get a little bit of
a drum roll right over here
we see that acceleration cancels with
acceleration
and we are left with mass times
v squared over two mv squared
over two which is exactly what we had
right over here
so the work necessary to accelerate an
object of mass
m from zero speed to a speed of
v is exactly this and that's how much
energy is then stored in
that object by virtue of its motion and
if you don't have energy loss it could
in theory
do this much work